welcome to how to think like Shakespeare
an examination of Shakespeare across
disciplines i'm here with jim Shapiro
and Carol Gilligan and right now we are
going to be talking about Shakespeare
retold there's now a entirely separate
canon of retellings of Shakespeare we
have you know plays films novels even
digital media like shakes Palin or
Facebook handle I got the call of a
lifetime the other day from a federal
appellate judge and DC kanisa you know
doing the Shakespeare moot court on the
trial of Agincourt the questions were
did Henry the fifth commit war crimes
either an invading France or in killing
the prisoners of war and answer was yes
and yes to both questions and did the
rest of the panel of lawyers and judges
agree with you actually it was yes I
mean there was a split but the majority
went with yes and yes with my answers
and I mean they were both liberal and
conservative judges and I'm not really
so focused on the outcome but rather on
the quality of the conversation there
was a kind of suppleness to it because
we were talking about Shakespeare so
obviously we're talking about to George
W Bush commit war crimes and invading
Iraq and Afghanistan so treatment of
detainees violating the Geneva
Conventions if you actually try and have
that conversation where everybody has a
dog in the fight there's always blood on
the floor but there's something about
refracting exactly the same questions or
Shakespeare where people are much more
willing to concede points much more
willing to be I think supple is the word
I keep coming back to in a way that they
converse with each other and ended up
being a much more humane conversation
did anybody ask why we still love Henry
the fifth even though we know he
committed war crimes that question to my
memory did not come up but what I did
come away from the exercise thinking
about was actually George W Bush was
very similar to Henry the fifth it's
just that he didn't win his encore so if
it'd one is often Corps he would have
had all the forms of authority that
Shakespeare gave to Henry the fifth I
think foreshadowing vapor in this
because Faber says that there's food
authority cars
authority and legal authority and you
know hundreds of fifth is a perfect
storm of all forms of authority you know
so too is George W Bush when he was
standing on the rumble of 911 you know
so that's why people compare Henry the
fifth George W Bush so often you know
but he didn't win his Audion course of
the judgment of history of against him
so my take on this is actually less that
we should you know make the consistency
favor george w bush then we should make
a disfavor Henry the fifth and for me
what's interesting is that we know Henry
the fifth acts criminally not just to
the French prisoners but to his own men
and yet were made to feel his charisma
and love and admire him at the end of
this play which I hate that feeling that
wells up of admiration for him because
he's as Machiavellian as anybody in
Shakespeare but Shakespeare nudges and
us into that uncomfortable space will
was supposed to applaud him right and
that's of inheritance from Falstaff I
think that kind of Teflon code it's the
final scene the catherine is not a
pleasant scene it's a rape set exactly
what's yours is mine that's it and she
has no voice and she doesn't even get
speaker on language yeah that's not yet
that's it is he showing us something
about this kind of heroism and what
happens to a man who has to be really
you know rested from his friendship with
Falstaff and cast into this role I mean
some ways we could also talk about Obama
I'm reminded of the line from Emma where
it's a visit perfect and being much too
short I feel like each one of these
segments a lot for hours thank you so
much for your insights but to see more
of this conversation please visit big
thing calm for our Shakespeare series